Moin Leute, oh moin ist gut, ist egal es geht immer.
Hat jemand von euch schon mal einen Raspberry Pi mit QEMO auf dem Desktop emuliert?
Oder es muss doch nicht mal ein Raspberry Pi sein in irgendeiner Armkiste.
Ich wollte nur wissen, ob das normal ist, dass das so extremst abfahrklangsam ist.
Das ist nicht einfach nur langsam, also das ist wirklich unnutzbar langsam, selbst wenn
man Zeit hat.
Das kann man komplett vergessen.
Ich hab mir überlegt, ob ich nicht mit QEMO irgendwas cross-compile für Arm, aber das
ist ja unendlich langsam.
Der Small Access Point ist auch da Moin, da sind sie alle, Pogu, HiIQ Chat wieder am Start
oder der Giga-Chat, der Giga-Chat ist am Start, der Giga-Chat-Chat.
So Leute, wir gucken uns heute mal Amazon Prime an, aber ich wette mit euch, es gibt nur Müll.
Das war die letzte Prime-Day, die letzten Cyber-Week-Mondays-Special-Sales und so war
alles Müll.
Ganz viel billig China-Chinesen-Kram und Zeug, was kein Mensch braucht und einfach
nur sinnlos.
Ich denke mal, so ist es jetzt auch, Leute ich hab ein Problem, ich weiß ich bin jetzt
gerade im Stream-On gekommen, aber ich muss nochmal aufs Klo, das hab ich vergessen vorher.
Ich hab angemacht, bevor ich noch aufs Klo komme, Leute ich muss mal kurz aufs Klo.
Ich hab angemacht, bevor ich noch aufs Klo komme, Leute ich muss mal kurz aufs Klo kommen,
Leute ich muss mal kurz aufs Klo kommen, Leute ich muss mal kurz aufs Klo kommen, Leute
ich muss mal kurz aufs Klo kommen Leute ich muss mal kurz aufs Klo kommen, Leute
ich muss mal kurz aufs Klo kommen, Leute ich muss mal kurz aufs Klo kommen, Leute
Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Die служte die Magde Hand auf für ein bisschen.
Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Okay Leute, das war nötig.
Oh, jetzt kann's losgehen.
Komm mal hier, what the fuck, ich bin auf dem Klo und es gibt hier die mega Subscrip-
a-Subscrip-kri-bierungs-Aktion.
Äh, Betai Golds hat 10 Subs gegiftet.
Dankeschön.
Wer hat denn Glück gehabt?
Zeigt mal her.
Äh, Dankudrix kriegt was.
ShockOps Gaming.
Mochi Xp-
Den hab ich letztens schon öfters mal gesehen.
Der Name, der kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
Der hat letztens ziemlich viel im Stream rumgespammt.
Mochi hab ich auch schon mal gesehen.
Jesu-
Jesutz-
Chris-
Christutz hat was gekriegt.
Nora Love Pancakes, die hab ich auch schon mal gesehen.
Ähm, Matt Weil sagt mir auch was.
Den anderen bin ich-
Phippsen könnt ich auch mal gesehen haben, schon.
Ich bin jetzt nicht so sicher.
Was sagst du zum Amazon Firetap?
Ja, ich find's nicht schlecht.
Also es ist für ein ultra, ultra, ultra low-end Tablet ganz okay.
Naja, wenn du kein Gerät mit Google Play willst, dann willst du wahrscheinlich auch
kein Gerät mit Google App Store, äh, mit Amazon App Store drauf.
Das beste, was du machen kannst mit den Firetablets ist,
die Dinger, ich weiß nicht, ob man die aktuell noch flashen kann.
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher.
Aber du kannst sie auf jeden Fall deploaten mit der Amazon Fire Toolbox.
Und dann kannst du dann auch APK sideloaden und so was.
Also, ganz im Ernst,
ich finde das Firetablet ist zwar ein richtig preisleistungsmäßig gutes Tablet
für low, low, low-end, aber zum täglichen Arbeiten,
oder was heißt Arbeiten, zum täglichen Benutzen.
Ich weiß nicht, zumal das Display jetzt zum Video schauen auch nicht so wahnsinnig geiles.
Also ich hab hier selbst mehrere Firetablets,
aber die hab ich nicht interaktiv im Einsatz.
Die hab ich oben und unten im Flur hängen als Home Automation Dashboards.
Dafür sind sie gut.
Die machen aber auch nichts anderes, als ein Firefox offen haben den ganzen Tag.
Und mit der Kamera erkenne ich, ob einer da vorsteht.
Da gibt es glücklicherweise für Android bessere Automatisierungsmöglichkeiten als iPads.
Hol dir doch ein neues iPad, so teuer sind die Dinger doch gar nicht.
Was kostet ein neues iPad, 400 Euro?
Ich mein, dafür hast du wenigstens auch was mit Wumms.
Oder 300?
Ich würd mir einfach ein neues iPad, ganz normales holen.
Kein eher, kein sonst was, einfach ganz normales iPad.
Guck mal hier, zeig mal was kostender Kram.
Nee, nee, die sind nicht teuer.
Die iPads sind, finde ich generell, Tablets kann Android nicht mithalten.
Smartphones kann man sich drüber streiten,
aber bei Tablets, ja hier 379 oder so, war ich doch mit 400 Euro gar nicht.
Gut, die Minis gibt's doch, wobei die sind noch billiger, äh, noch teurer.
Nee, kostet gerade 79, also ich finde ganz ehrlich,
und dann hast du wenigstens auch was mit Wumms, das hast du die nächsten Jahre über
und das die nächsten Jahre auch noch schnell.
Ja, die zeigen Firefox an.
Also ich sehe nur Firefox, die zeigen mein Home Automation Dashboard,
also mein Home Assistant Dashboard an.
Im Fullscreen, die gehen aus nach ein paar Minuten
und ich hab, ich kann euch alleine nicht sagen, wie das heißt.
Ähm, ich hab da so eine App drauf, die erkennt, wenn man davor steht, über die Kamera.
Ich bin mir, ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, wie das Ding hieß.
Es kann auch sein, dass das in diesem Kiosk-Browser, den ich mal installiert hab,
dabei war, wobei ich, wie gesagt, Firefox jetzt,
im Fullscreen hab.
Ähm, ich weiß nicht mehr, wie das Ding hieß.
Zumindest ist das eine App, die checkt halt den Kamerainput
und wenn man davor steht, schaltet das Tablet, macht das Display an und entsperrt sich.
Das geht aber alles nur in der Android.
Also generell, das ist der Vorteil von Android,
wenn du so Automatisierungs-Sachen machen willst, ist es einfach viel, viel besser als unter iOS.
Apple erlaubt halt vieles nicht.
Dafür, ja, ist es halt auch für jeden eine Hinz- und Kunst zu benutzen.
Ja, die sind mit Sicherheit günstiger.
Die ganzen, also, das ist eh eines der wenigen Sachen, die sich je, bei jedem...
Guck mal.
Was sich bei jedem Prime day lohnt, ist...
Wait a minute.
Muss man sich dafür einloggen?
Nee, oder?
Angucken kann man sich's auch so.
Weil ich hab meinen Login jetzt nicht hier.
Für Amazon.
Okay, angucken kann man sich auch...
Es wäre ja auch blöd, wenn du dir das nicht angucken kannst.
Wenn du...
Weil die wollen den Leuten ja irgendwie dazu verleihen.
Guck mal, hier hast du die Dinger.
Das sind doch die ganzen Tablets.
Fire HD 10.
Das ist teurer geworden.
Warte mal, ich muss mal kurz bei mir aufs Handy...
Wo ist mein Handy?
Hä, wo ist mein Handy?
Oh, das hab ich aufm Klo vergessen.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Okay, cool.
So, klassisch Handy-Klovergel.
Klar, kennt ihr das nicht.
Ich vergess öfters mein Handy aufm Klo.
So, ich guck jetzt nämlich mal kurz bei Amazon,
für wie viel ich das mir vor ein paar Jahren gekauft hab.
Das ist natürlich andere Generation.
Aber macht ja nichts.
Mal kurz gucken, wie sich da die Preise entwickelt haben.
Fire.
Fire HD 8, Fire HD 10 hab ich gekauft.
Zwei Stück.
Order Details.
Damals haben die gekostet...
Oh, das ist günstiger geworden.
Damals hab ich...
Ach, Moment.
Zwei Stück für 99.
Ach nee, jeweils.
99 Euro haben die damals noch gekostet.
Und jetzt kostet es mal Prime 79.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz okay.
Also, wenn man sowas haben möchte, wie gesagt,
als Tablet zum täglichen Benutzen,
finde ich es jetzt persönlich nicht so,
dass man so ein Tablet zum täglichen Benutzen
finde ich es jetzt persönlich nicht so geil.
Aber wenn man beispielsweise ein Dashboard braucht
oder man sich ein...
Ich-Bilder-Rahmen-Wünscht in der Richtung
zum Sachen anzeigen oder so.
Also, für so...
nicht...
viel mit dem Finger drauf rumgetatschte interaktive Sachen
sind die Dinger gut.
Weil das ist eben Android drunter.
Und Android kannst du einfach deutlich besser automatisieren
und Dinger mitmachen als iOS.
Ja, deswegen.
Dafür kann man es empfehlen.
Ansonsten...
Ich weiß nicht.
Nee, ansonsten nicht.
Externe Platten.
Ja, ich könnte tatsächlich...
Jetzt gucken wir.
Gucken wir gleich mal.
Ich könnte auch wirklich noch eine externe Platte gebrauchen.
Richtig fette externe Platte könnte ich gebrauchen.
Pepo.
Fett.
Platte.
Ja, aber da will ich mal ein bisschen Smart Home gucken.
Und ich brauche auf jeden Fall noch...
Da muss ich nämlich gleich...
Das müssen wir gleich mal hier.
Prime Day.
Vielleicht gibt es da einen.
Kützig.
Ich meine, wer weiß, wie knapp das Gas wird im Winter.
Na, so zwei Radiatoren schaden da nicht, wenn man mal welche hat.
Aber das ist alles Crap.
Die will man nicht haben.
Ich will so einen klassischen Öl-Radiator haben.
Nur falls es wirklich im Winter mit Gas nichts wird.
Ich muss euch jetzt mal ehrlich sagen.
Dieses Rumgemache mit Hilfe im Winter wird es kalt und so.
Also, es gibt da zwei Sachen, die sich so...
Ich weiß, die widersprechen sich.
Die widersprechen sich.
Aber zwei Sachen, die mir da so durch den Kopf rumschweren.
Das erste ist, es wurde ja noch von nicht allzu langer Zeit öfters demonstriert.
So nach dem Motto, Energie sparen und auch beim Kalten daheim sitzen.
Ich meine, okay, so haben sich die Leute wahrscheinlich nicht vorgestellt.
Und das zweite ist, ich finde es ein absolutes...
Also, wenn das wirklich dazu kommt, dass Leute ihre Häuser nicht heizen können in Deutschland,
dann...
Es wird wahrscheinlich keine Konsequenzen haben.
Aber das ist ein komplettes Versagen auf ganzer Ebene.
Ich meine, überlegt euch mal.
Es gibt außer drei weitere Länder auf der ganzen Welt.
Drei weitere Länder auf der ganzen Welt haben mehr Geld als wir.
Wie kann es sein, dass wir ernsthaft Probleme bekommen,
dass wir als viertreichtes Land der Welt im Winter eventuell frieren müssen?
The fuck?
Da stimmt doch irgendwas nicht.
Also, das ist echt auf ganzer Linie verschissen, Alter.
Das kann nicht sein.
Einfach Winterjacke anziehen.
Ja, aber ich habe eh keine Probleme im Winter mit Temperaturen.
Weil ich habe die Klimaanlage hier im Arbeitszimmer.
Die kann auch heizen, drüben im Schlafzimmer.
Die Klimaanlage, ich habe genug Heizlüfter.
Ich habe mir letztens noch einen Heizlüfter gekauft.
Also, ich habe da keine Probleme mit.
Aber ich weiß ja auch nicht, da kenne ich mich tatsächlich zu wenig aus.
Wenn wir wirklich Probleme kriegen, was Gas und sowas angeht.
Ob wir da nicht vielleicht auch Probleme mit Stromversorgung bekommen?
Keine Ahnung.
Prime Sub, Prime Day, excellent.
Das dürfte wahrscheinlich das Beste am ganzen Prime Days sein.
Aber das kann echt nicht sein.
Es kann wirklich nicht sein, dass wir als viertreiches Land
uns ernsthaft Gedanken machen sollen, ob wir frieren.
Und ich denke sogar, dass man das gar nicht so sehr auf eine Sache zeigen kann.
Ich gehe einfach davon aus, dass die letzten 16 oder 20 Jahre
über ganz viele Dinge verkackt wurden,
dass es jetzt am Ende unterm Strich zu sowas kommt.
Sicherlich hat vielleicht die aktuelle Regierung auch was zu beigetragen,
aber ich denke mal, dass die da gar nicht mal so viel Einfluss drauf hatten.
Aber trotzdem, es ist mir ehrlich gesagt scheißegal, wer dran schuld ist.
Es ist mir vollkommen egal.
Ich will, dass es im Winter warm ist.
Aber da hat wahrscheinlich jeder andere Ansicht, woran das jetzt liegt.
Letztendlich, ich sage euch ganz ehrlich, mir ist es scheißegal,
ich will, dass es im Winter warm ist.
Und es kann nicht sein, dass wir als viertreiches Land der Welt
uns wirklich Gedanken machen müssen, ob Leute frieren im Winter.
Das ist genau das, was ich mir auch denke.
Mir ist es scheißegal, macht euren Job, wofür ihr da seid.
Das, was ich auch jeden Tag mache, wo ich 40 plus Prozent davon abgeben muss.
Also macht halt was Gescheites damit.
Das Video mit den letzten Encrypt-Zertifikaten hat super geholfen.
DNS-Rebindschutz und DNS-Rewrite waren noch zwei Dinge, die notwendig waren.
Warst du der mit dem Power-DNS?
Nee, du warst jemand anderes, oder?
Ich komme manchmal ein bisschen durcheinander bei den ganzen Fragen in den Streams.
Du warst nicht der mit dem Power-DNS, oder?
Nee, du hast nach dem Let's Encrypt-Wort gefragt.
Das schon gesehen.
Ich muss das mal am zweiten Bildschirm aufmachen,
weil ich immer nicht weiß, was dahinter steckt.
Ja, das verfolge ich schon ganz lange.
Die hatten letztens einen Playtest.
Haben die das jetzt wirklich released?
Ich verfolge das schon seit Jahren im Discord, den BF3-Reality-Mod.
Haben die das jetzt released?
Dann muss ich mir das tatsächlich mal anschauen.
Das letzte Mal habe ich nämlich gesehen, dass die für Influencers
einen internen Playtest hatten.
Ich habe mir schon überlegt, ob ich mich anmelden soll.
Das müssen wir uns tatsächlich mal angucken.
Was ist deine Meinung zu Red Hat Enterprise Linux?
Meinst du jetzt zur Distribution?
Oder ob man sich das kaufen sollte?
Weil die Distribution ist im Enterprise-Umfeld
eigentlich das mit das beliebteste.
Aber kaufen, nein, weil viel zu teuer.
Du kannst aber Nachbauten verwenden.
Früher war CentOS, jetzt ist es Rocky Linux.
Aber das ist leider nicht mehr das, was es mal vor ein paar Jahren war,
weil Red Hat da keinen Bock mehr drauf hat.
Es war eine super Alternative.
Ansonsten, ganz ehrlich, ich persönlich würde es nicht verwenden.
Wenn ich eines der größeren Enterprise-Distributionen verwenden will,
dann würde ich Ubuntu.
Da ist ja meistens wichtig, dass es Support gibt und Updates und LTS-Garantien.
Dann würde ich irgendeinen Ubuntu-LTS nehmen.
Ja, Red Hat hat, glaube ich, längeren Support.
Ich glaube, Red Hat hat 10 Jahre oder so ab Release.
Ubuntu hat LTS plus 5 Jahre.
Aber ganz im Ernst, du willst kein 10 Jahre als Linux verwenden,
auch wenn es 10 Jahre supportet wird.
By the way, ratet mal, was wir auf der Arbeit intern
auf ganz viele Linux-Server verwenden, so auf ca. 2000 Stück.
Da kommt ihr nie drauf, weil ich gerade gesagt habe,
man sollte ein Linux keine 10 Jahre verwenden.
Aber wir verwenden CentOS 7 an vielen Stellen noch.
Ein CentOS 7, das aktuelle CentOS.
Ein CentOS 4 haben wir tatsächlich auch noch,
habe ich letztens gefunden.
Das ist irgendein so uralt wahren Wirtschaftssystem,
was ausgeschaltet ist und nur 2-mal im Jahr eingeschaltet werden muss.
Das ist ein CentOS 4 von 2008 oder so.
CentOS 8 ist nicht verfügbar, ja, das haben sie abgeblasen.
Aber CentOS 7 wird bis zum End of Life supported.
Wobei ich sagen muss, das System, was wir haben mit CentOS 4,
ist eigentlich ein CentOS 5, was sich als CentOS 4 ausgibt.
Wer das nicht versteht, macht nichts.
Ich verstehe das auch nicht so genau, aber es ist so.
Ja, stimmt, ich erinnere mich wieder.
FEDORA
Ne, Fedora, ganz ehrlich ich mag
eigentlich so gut wie keine RPM basierte Distributionen.
Ja ey, wir fahren auf der Arbeit CentOS.
Ich kenne mich damit gut, das macht eigentlich keinen Unterschied.
Linux ist Linux.
Ob du da jetzt ein Ab drauf hast, ein Pacman drauf hast oder ein Yam-DNF drauf hast, das
ist eigentlich ziemlich egal.
Richtig, so ist es, historisch gewachsen.
So, also, wir gucken jetzt mal ein bisschen bei Amazon rein.
Also Radiatoren gibt es nicht, habe ich schon gesehen.
Es gibt Ventile, die, warum auch immer, Ventile sind und da verkauft werden.
Wir schauen mal und zwar, also, wir gucken mal nach externen Festplatten, das wird mich
tatsächlich interessieren und jetzt wo wir gerade dabei sind, BF3 Reality Mod, haben
die das jetzt released?
Ach tatsächlich, haben sie es jetzt geschafft?
Ich verfolge die seit Jahren schon im Discord.
Das hat übrigens nichts mit Battlefield 2 Reality Mod zu tun, das sind andere Leute.
Ja, ich werde es mir auf jeden Fall angucken.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass Battlefield 3 so auf Superrealismus richtig gut funktioniert,
aber ich gucke es mir an.
Du hast heute einen Ausbildungsvertrag unterschrieben.
Ach nee, das mit dem Heute war eins unten drunter.
Ausbildungsvertrag unterschrieben, 1057 Euro erstes Ausbildungsjahr ist wild, ich kann
es überhaupt nicht beurteilen, ob das wild ist.
Das stimmt aber auf jeden Fall nicht schlecht.
Ich überlege nämlich gerade, was ich im ersten Ausbildungsjahr bekommen habe, es war auf
jeden Fall nicht so viel, das kann ich dir sagen, aber bei mir ist das ja auch schon
etwas länger her.
Ich glaube, ich habe 600 Euro oder irgendwie sowas gekriegt im ersten Ausbildungsjahr.
Du kannst nur hoffen, dass du nach der Ausbildung dann, also, dass es dann nicht nur minimal
steigt nach der Ausbildung, dann freust du dich jetzt und nach der Ausbildung kommen
sie an, ja, also Frau Kali, sie sind doch bestimmt mit 1300 Euro im Monat zufrieden
und dann sagst du dann, naja, gut, nee, dann gehe ich woanders hin, sind was sind eigentlich
drei?
Ehe woanders hin, ja, dann ist egal.
Ganz viele Leute haben sich anscheinend ein Tablet bestellt, war schon Thema hier gerade
vor ein paar Minuten.
Gibt es eine Playlist, ja?
Relaxing and calming music from Super Mario Series, die lauter können wir schon noch
machen, weil ist eigentlich laut genug, das ist bloß der eine Track, der so langsam ist,
also ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich verkürze, stand ja bei mir damals auch zur Diskussion,
ich habe absichtlich gesagt, ich verkürze meine Ausbildung nicht und wisst ihr warum?
Weil ich einfach nur ultra faul bin und ich wollte noch ein bisschen Däumchen drehen
in der Berufsschule und nichts machen.
Geld hat mir damals schon gereicht, wie gesagt, ihr kennt mich, ich gebe ja nichts aus, deswegen
ist gut, dass ich trotz beschissener Stonks Kurse dieses Jahr endlich mal angefangen
habe, mein Geld sinnvoll zu investieren, weil es liegt einfach nur rum und das ist ja noch
schlechter.
Ich wollte einfach noch ein Jahr länger faul sein, deswegen habe ich meine Ausbildung nicht
verkürzt.
Du hast eine zweite Grafikkarte, das kriegst du mit deinem Ausbildungsgeld hin, da musst
du ja auch nicht verkürzen, aber ehrlich gesagt, das mit dem verkürzen oder nicht, ist Geschmackssache
und hängt auch, finde ich, ganz entscheidend dran, wie der Ausbildungsbetrieb so ist, also
ob man da wirklich was lernt, wenn man da nämlich wirklich was lernt, ist es vielleicht gar
nicht so schlecht, das dritte Jahr zu machen, wenn man da aber nur seine Zeit absitzt, ist
eh egal.
Alles in Bitcoin, klar, hudel, macht da bup, Kekkel, Alter, ok, es ist aber nicht mal ultra
viel weiter runter gegangen, seitdem ich das letzte Mal geguckt habe, da war das schon
so hier.
Serverzentrum ist unter der Erde, dass das Rechenzentrum im Keller ist, ist relativ
häufig so.
Hab ich euch eigentlich schon mal, bevor wir jetzt Amazon gucken, hab ich euch eigentlich
schon die Story erzählt, warum wir in der alten Firma das Rechenzentrum im, äh, ich
das jetzt misst erzählen, im siebten Stock, nee, nee, nee, nicht in der Wohnung, nein,
nein, nein, nicht in der Wohnung, nein, das meine ich nicht, das weiß ich nicht, äh,
warum wir in der alten Firma das Rechenzentrum im siebten Stock hatten, vom, äh, ich rede
nicht von der Wohnung, das war, also normalerweise würde man ja sagen, ja was macht denn das
Rechenzentrum im siebten Stock, das ist ja total unsinnig, und das hat auch immer wieder
Probleme gemacht, weil jedes Mal, wenn dort neue Storage-Systeme reingestellt werden sollten,
mussten sie irgendein Architektenbüro finden, was die Statik schön rechnet, dass man das
noch reinstellen darf, zwischenzeitlich haben sie sogar den Boden verstärkt, dort wo Storage-Systeme
standen, ganz im Ernst, wenn das Storage-System durch die Decke bricht, und da sitzt einer
drunter, ich glaube, also platt ist gar nicht mehr der richtige Ausdruck für, ich glaube
der pulverisiert, komplett, stellt euch mal vor, es fällt euch ein mehrere Tonnen schweres
desintegriert, ja, es stellt euch mal vor, es fällt euch ein mehrere Tonnen schweres
Storage-System von zweieinhalb oder von drei Meter Höhe auf den Kopf, also du bist wahrscheinlich
noch nicht mal Matsch, du bist so in Teile, dass man dich überhaupt nicht mehr zuordnen
kann, was du mal gewesen bist, Helm, der rätte dich bestimmt, so zumindest auf dem kleinen
C, ja, wir hatten mal bei einem Rechenzentrum Umzug, einem, dem ist ein fetter Server auf
dem Fuß gefallen, so richtig schön mit der Kante vom Metallgehäuse, MonkaS, alter, zumindest,
das hat richtig Probleme gemacht mit dem Storage, und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, warum
war das Rechenzentrum nicht im Keller, und im Keller war Platz, im Keller war nämlich
ein Mini-Mini-Mini-Rechenzentrum, in der Abstellkammer mit einem Rack drin, das war letztendlich für
die Hausverkabelung, aber warum war das nicht im Keller, man hätte es super im Keller machen
können, und die Antwort ist, es war nicht im Keller, weil, es kann sein, dass ich euch
das schon erzählt habe, es war nicht im Keller, weil Leute vom Vorstand ihren Parkplatz nicht
räumen wollten, die haben gesagt, ich bin im Vorstand, ich bin wichtig und ich brauche
in der Garage einen Parkplatz, und das Rechenzentrum kann da nicht hin, und dann haben die lieber
das Rechenzentrum im siebten Stock immer wieder architektenmäßig schön rechnen lassen,
anstatt sich woanders hinzustellen mit ihrem Auto, relatable, jaja, und deswegen war das
Rechenzentrum im siebten Stock, das ist auch eines der größten PP-Ger-Entscheidungen,
die ich da managmenttechnisch je gesehen habe, ja, das wäre wahrscheinlich weniger aufwendig
gewesen, man hätte einen Lift gebaut, das im siebten Stock das Parkhaus wäre, so, aber
jetzt kommen wir zur Runde Amazon an, also, schauen wir mal, wie es aussieht mit externen
Festplatten, wo der Unterschied ist, ähm, wait a minute,
nee, ich hab grad gedacht, du spammst Reflink, aber das ist nicht so, äh, wo ist der Unterschied,
bleibt mal her, äh, ich seh keinen Unterschied, fühlt mir alles gleich aus, ach nee, Fire
HD 10 Tablet, ja, das ist, das ist general überholt, das ist gebraucht, das ist gebraucht,
das ist achter, das eine ist mit Amazon, und das eine ist ohne Amazon-Krempel, ach nee,
das ist ein Plus, und das andere ist ein, nee, das ist auch general überholt, steht
auch da, nee, das da, das ist mit Spezialangeboten, und das ist ohne Spezialangebote, das eine
ist, bei mir steht da nix mit 39 und 37, ach, das hier, Special Offers, mit Spezial, dann
hab ich keine Ahnung, was der Unterschied ist, ähm, wahrscheinlich gar nix, wahrscheinlich
ist gar kein Unterschied, weil es wieder Amazon Pepega Time angesagt, nee, das ist general
überholt, das ist general überholt, und das hier ist neu, das eine ist general überholt
und das andere neu, ich mein, warum man für zwei Euro sich general überholtes holen
soll, keine Ahnung, weiß wahrscheinlich nur Amazon, dann würd ich mir immer Neues holen,
Omega Lul, ja, aber richtig, Hyper Omega Poggers Lul, oder kappalul.com, wie meine neue Domain,
so sagt.
Also gucken wir mal externe Festpläne, also Prime Day, okay, obligatorisch, obligatorisch
gucken, ob's günstige SSDs gibt, ich brauch keine SSDs, aber SSDs lohnen sich beim Prime
Day eigentlich fast immer, wobei man sich natürlich vom Prime Day nicht gebaten lassen
darf, nehmen wir mal zum Beispiel die hier, das dürfte so eines der, also diese Crucial
MX500 und BX500, das ist ja sau beliebte SSDs, Amazon gebated gerne, ich könnte wetten,
Evo, Moment, müssen wir mal gucken, Prime Day, Evo 870, sind die nicht schon bei 970,
kostet 2TB, 455, so, jetzt schauen wir mal, begeits halt, weil Amazon gebated ja gerne,
Evo 2TB, okay, das ist tatsächlich ganz gut, das ist nicht schlecht, das ist, das würde
ich sagen, kann man sich dann tatsächlich mal geben, das finde ich okay, ja, da sage
ich jetzt gar nichts gegen, 155 Euro versus hier 193, okay, das ist doch in Ordnung, ja,
was kostet denn die 970, okay, ne, die ist ein bisschen teurer, ein bisschen ist gut
100 Euro teurer, so, also Prime Day, die obligatorische Sache nach SSDs, wie gesagt, ich brauche keine
SSDs, ich habe genug SSDs aktuell da, aber SSDs ist ja eine Sache, die man normalerweise
nie genug haben kann, die Dinge habe ich ausprobiert, da habe ich zwei Stück schon, von diesen Sandisk
Extreme Portables, die finde ich fragwürdig, weil die verbrauchen mehr Strom als USB laut
Spezifikation liefern kann, was dazu führt, dass die an manchen Systemen unstabil an Stable
sind, das sollte nicht der Fall sein, ist es aber leider, und wer die Dinge an einem Raspberry
Pi betreiben will, kann es komplett vergessen, weil der Raspberry Pi noch nicht mal maximale
USB Spannung liefern kann, ich glaube der Raspberry Pi kann maximal 1,5 Ampere, ne 0,7, ich kann
es nicht, ne, warte mal, was kannst du über USB machen, 1,5 und der Raspberry Pi kann
plus 0,7, ich bin mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt aus dem Kopf nicht ganz sicher, zumindest
liefert der Raspberry Pi nicht das, was maximal möglich wäre und dementsprechend kannst du
es knicken, vor allem, wenn du zusätzlich am USB Port noch was anderes betreiben wolltest,
ich hatte ja mal einen Raspberry Pi im Einsatz, mit USB TV Tuner und USB SSD, kannst du komplett,
aber wirklich komplett vergessen, das System fliegt dir laufend um die Ohren, weil die
Platten weg, weg fliegen und read only gehen und alles, weil zu wenig Strom, ja mit einem
extra Hub das geht, mit dem aktiven Hub funktioniert das, doch aktiver Hub funktioniert, warum soll
das nicht funktionieren, ich hab selbst einen aktiven Hub dran gehabt, das funktioniert
besser, aber auch nicht wirklich gut, zumal du dann massig Kabelsalat hast, wozu du eigentlich
gerade einen Raspberry Pi holst, dass du das nicht hast, doch ich hab das mit dem Hub,
Hub war gar kein Problem, ich hatte so einen billig Anker USB Hub, so einen China-Chinesen,
kann man hier USB Hub mal gucken, ob es hier gerade fürs Ding gibt, ja das ist er, das
ist er, wobei ob das der ist, weiß ich nicht, die sehen alle so aus, so einen in der Richtung
hab ich als USB Hub, aber ne das kann ja nicht sein, weil das nicht mit Stromanschluss ist,
dann weiß ichs auch nicht, kann man mit dem aktiven Hub auch den Raspberry Pi betreiben,
ja, du kannst theoretisch den Raspberry Pi an den Hub stecken und dann dort den Raspberry
Pi noch an USB, das funktioniert, also kannst du machen, ja, aber dann hast du das Problem,
dass der Hub auch irgendwann zu wenig Strom liefert, weil der Hub hat ja auch bloß maximal
irgendwie, was ist das, 5V, 2A und der Raspberry Pi braucht ja standardmäßig schon wirklich
Limit was USB hergibt, also deswegen, als offizielle Raspberry Pi Netzteile hat glaube
ich 5,1V mit 3A und das machen die meisten USB Dinger gar nicht, du brauchst das nicht,
du brauchst das wirklich in absoluten Spitzenlastzeiten, die 15 Watt, die der Raspberry Pi 4 verbraucht,
aber trotzdem, es hat schon seinen Sinn, dass die ein eigenes Netzteil dabei haben,
also USB Geräte am Pi und den Pi selber über den aktiven USB Hub betreiben, also wenn du
willst, dass dein System öfters mal abkackt und die Festplatte read-only geht, weil es
Probleme gibt, dann kannst du das machen, ich würde es aber auf jeden Fall nicht empfehlen,
kaputt gehen kann da nichts, weil du kannst Daten verlieren, ja, aber hardware-technisch
kann da nichts kaputt gehen, aber es ist halt unstabil, es, fuck, das will man nicht machen.
Warum ist diese Platte eigentlich noch so wahnsinnig beliebt, da gibt es auch mittlerweile bessere
Alternativen, oder?
Das Ding ist so der Evergreen seit den letzten 5 Jahren, diese MX500-Series, ist Lexa, China-Chinesen-Zeug?
Also, SSDs, weiß nicht, ich hab genug SSDs, wir gucken gerade mal, externe Festplatte,
oder externe SSD, externe SSD ist bescheuert, ich brauch Speicherplatz, ich brauch Pepofet-Speicherplatz,
5TB zu wenig, 12TB könnte man vielleicht nochmal drüber reden, das ist aber teurer
als eine 12TB normale Platte, oder?
Das ist eigentlich nicht so, nicht so nice, gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal, HDD im Zweifels
kann sie noch, 2TB, wisst ihr, warum kann man den Kram, also die Suche bei Amazon ist
wirklich sehr pepega, oder, warum kann ich die Festplatten jetzt bitte schön nicht nach
Größe sortieren?
Manchmal geht das, manchmal geht das nicht, also manchmal kannst du sortieren, manchmal
Computer und Electronics, warum kann ich die Festplatten nicht sortieren, nach Größe
mann Amazon, was ist das denn schon wieder?
Aber das sieht alles nicht so aus, als würde sich das groß, also das ist ganz schön, ich
glaube 8TB für 190 ist glaube ich echt nicht günstig, schauen wir mal kurz Geizhals, aber
ich glaube das ist nicht, nicht, oben rechts sort by, die Sachen mit Größe filtern wir
meistens über das linke, aber das funktioniert dann auch nicht so, ganz ehrlich Amazon Suche
ist einfach abfack, der einzige Grund warum der Amazon so viel verkauft ist, weil ihre
Empfehlungen ganz gut sind, so Festplatten, HDD, TB3, ah Thunderbolt, Harddisk, SATA,
3 pro Terabyte, guck mal hier, also du kriegst hier, gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal die 8er,
ne nicht bis 8, ab 8, ja ok, das geht tatsächlich, wobei ich mir keine 8er mehr reinhauen würde,
ach Moment ich muss nach preis, nicht nach preis pro, na gut in dem Fall ist es eigentlich,
wait a minute, das ist teurer bei Amazon, wie das, ja dann ist ppega, dann lohnt sich das
überhaupt nicht, ne, gibt es 18TB, wenn es 18TB gibt günstig, dann wird das gekauft,
no pass, wie groß, wie groß, 18TB, das ist doch bestimmt so, warum keine 8TB mehr, weil
preisleistungsmäßig, ok das stimmt nicht, ich glaube preisleistungsmäßig sind 8TB
relativ gut aktuell, aber du bekommst halt für etwas, sag mal vielleicht nicht ganz
so gut preisleistungsmäßig, bekommst du aber halt schon 12, 14TB plus, mit nicht so viel
mehr preis pro Terabyte und ich finde es einfach besser, anstatt 2 Platten reinzustecken, lieber
eine große reinzustecken, generell großes reinstecken, gachi bass ist immer nicht verkehrt.
Du hast dir ein paar, ja also wenn das preisleistungsmäßig für dich das beste ist, kannst du machen,
also ich persönlich würde mir keine 8TB Platten mehr reinschieben, so, also da ist glaube
ich nichts dabei, wir lassen uns mal kurz inspirieren von den Amazon Empfehlungen, ja
das Problem ist, du kannst das alles machen und das ist vielleicht performanstechnisch
auch gar nicht schlecht, falls du da irgendwie drauf auf Magnetplatten Performance schielst,
aber du musst dich dann halt um den ZFS kümmern, du musst dir dann überlegen, ok, was mache
ich denn jetzt am besten für den Raid Level, dann musst du dir da Zeug zurechtlegen, gucken
dass du 10% Platz reservierst, weil es ZFS ist und bei einer Platte ist es halt überhaupt
kein Problem, du machst eine Platte, spiegelst die einmal nachts und wenn was davon verreckt
ist egal, holst dir eine neue Platte und Ruhe, nachdem ich eh SSD Cache dazwischen hab, juckt
mich gar nicht mehr, ob die Platte irgendwie jetzt lahm ist, 2TB SSD Cache, ich könnte
nochmal ein zweites, 2TB dazustecken und fertig, ist gut, dass ich mir diese Erweiterungskarte
gekauft hab für den SSD Cache, 18TB sind SMR oder CMR, ich weiß es nicht, aber es muss
ja immer dabei stehen, mein Cache ist nur Read, nö, das ist der SSD, die ist Read und
Write, naja, du brauchst eine SSD und du brauchst eine Platte wo du es letztendlich drauf schreibst,
weil ansonsten würdest du direkt auf die SSD schreiben, das bleibt drauf, dann wäre es
ja kein SSD Cache, wenn ich übers Netzwerklaufwerk irgendwas hinschiebe, dann geht das mit 10G
auf die SSD drauf, ich meine außer die SSD ist voll, dann natürlich nicht und dann wird
das langsam aber sicher runtergemoved auf die Magnetplatte, äh das ist Write, das ist
Write Cache, nicht Read Cache, Write Cache, weil Read Cache, ja dann bräuchte man, nee,
Write Cache, ja mach da, wenn Stromausfall ist, sind die Sachen ja noch auf der SSD drauf
und wenn ich die Kiste wieder einfahre, werden die Sachen halt weitergemoved auf die Magnetplatten,
das funktioniert, also Amazon, was möchtest du uns heute verkaufen, billige Werkzeugkisten,
die werde ich mir schon mal definitiv nicht kaufen, TP Link and More, ok zeig mal her,
von Amazon Basics können wir safen, das ist gut, von Samsung können wir safen, von Netgear
können wir safen, wir safen ja so viel, dass wir am Ende fast mehr Geld haben als vorher,
zumindest wollen sie einem das weis machen, so noch mehr von Basics safen, ok wir safen
ja hier komplett unser Konto voll, so fertig gesaved, also zeig mal her, TP Link Steckdosen,
Nopers, Nope, was ist denn das, Access Point, warum sieht der so ppeger aus der Access Point,
brauchen wir nicht, brauchen wir nicht, brauchen wir nicht, da fällt mir was ein, vor ein paar
Jahren, ich überleg grad was es war, ob es Netgear oder Asus war, ein Routerhersteller,
also irgendein Gaming Routerhersteller angeschrieben, ist schon 3-4 Jahre her, ob ich das Gerät
nicht vorstellen möchte, ich bekomm das auch alles kostenlos, überlassen und so, da hab
ich ihn zurückgeschrieben so nach dem Motto, ja ich kann das Gerät gerne in einem Video
erwähnen, aber ich will das Gerät nicht benutzen, muss ich das benutzen um da drüber ein Video
zu machen, und dann hab ich gemeint, warum willst du das nicht benutzen, voll geiler
Gaming Router, ich hab hier mein Setup und das will ich nicht umschrauben, und irgendwie
waren die scharf darauf, dass ich es benutze, und dann ist da nix draus geworden, vorgestellt
hätte ich das ganze gar kein Problem, ganz ehrlich gibt es immer weniger und ist ein
Glücksfall noch welche zu bekommen, weil die China-Chinesen leider angefangen haben, also
hat 2 Gründe, die haben angefangen Geräte rauszugeben die gepatcht sind, ja wie gesagt
du musst erstmal welche kriegen, die noch flashbar sind, also es gibt 2 Sachen, die
haben ihre Geräte gepatcht, sodass dieses standardmäßige over the air flaschen nicht
funktioniert, dazu musste man die letzten paar Geräte schon aufschrauben um sie flaschen
zu können, und das nächste ist, die Geräte haben kein ESP866 oder ESP32 mehr und dementsprechend
ist mit TASMOTA flaschen eh nix, weil TASMOTA ist eine Firmware für den ESP866 und ESP32,
also sprich wenn da ein anderer Chip drin ist, geht TASMOTA logischerweise nicht mehr.
Du hast die Gosund bestellter Flashbar direkt von ihrer Webseite, zeig mal, schick mal einen
Link, Gosund, die haben sich immer noch nicht in Gesund umbenannt, Corona ist doch fast
vorbei, ist das die mit USB unten dran, ja die hier, die sind tatsächlich nicht schlecht,
falls die das sind, die ich auch mal bestellt hab, Gosund, ich glaub da sind die mit, naja
Pima Daumen Strommessung, also was das verbraucht, was dran hängt und zwei USB Anschlüssen
und halt eine normale Steckdose, die waren ganz okay, falls die das sind, die ich auch
habe, allerdings wie gesagt, keine Ahnung ob die noch flashbar sind, Shelley kannst du
auch mit TASMOTA flaschen, der Unterschied ist nur, dass du hier 4 China-Chinesen Steckdosen
bekommst, manchmal, wenn die im Angebot sind, für den Preis von einer Shelley Steckdose,
Gosund-Deutschland.de, die gibt's ja, 34,60 Euro, SP1 Zwischenstecker, bewerben die hiermit,
dass man die flashen kann oder, oder war das Zufall, bewerben die das irgendwo, dass die
flashbar sind, ahja guck mal, Shelley Smartplug gibt's, das hört sich übrigens aus, Shelley
Smartplug hört sich sehr Gatchibas-mäßig an, ja guck da bekommst du zwei Shelley Plugs,
hier bekommst du 4 Steckdosen für und die Shelley-Dinger sind in letzter Zeit ziemlich
teuer geworden, guck mal, Products, Shop, Shop, die haben mittlerweile auch Gott und
die Welt an Zeug, 17 Euro, also du bekommst, du bekommst genau zwei für den Preis von
China-Chinesen, 4 und Feature-technisch ist das hier auch besser, weil, Moment wo sind
die, guck mal, du bekommst die USB, sind die das mit USB, also die mit USB sind die, die
sind folgsten, ja, die Steckdose steckt jetzt nicht von unten, das ist blöd, haben die
USB, ne oder, ja dann die hier, dann die hier, mit Strommessung und USB und die am besten
da noch im 4er-Pack, die hab ich mir nämlich damals im Angebot gekauft, ich hab mir glaube
ich 3x4 gekauft und die konnten man alle noch flashen, naja nach oben und unten ist doch
nicht das Problem, nach vorne, nach vorne sind die ungefähr genauso groß, ja du hast
recht die sind größer aber dafür kannst du 2xUSB-Geräte anschließend kannst den Verbrauch
messen und hast einen ordentlichen Schalter dran, was du beim Shelly nicht hast, also ich
finde das sind die besten von denen die ich gekauft hab, China-Chinesen Zeug, ja, Gosund,
22 Euro, Leute das ist, aber wartet mal jetzt, ne, wartet mal ab, das ist ein echt guter
Preis, man müsste halt wissen ob die flashbar sind, wenn die flashbar sind dann geb ihm
rein damit, ist das überhaupt noch gültig, warum ist meine Playlist vorbei, Moment, wo
ist meine Playlist, doch Relaxing Music, ach bei de Gosund, das ist Aliexpress, Moment,
das sieht ein bisschen aus wie das Sale von Aliexpress, ne die Gosund Seite hat sich einfach
vom China-Chinesen Webseiten Design Ministerium diesen Counter machen lassen, endet in 8.445,
Leute jetzt wirds aber knapp, nur noch 8.445 Stunden left, mir juckt schon im Finger, ich
kanns das wird knapp, ganz ganz knapp, ok aber man hat natürlich hier, Gosund, ja kann
man die flashen oder nicht, das ist halt das Ding, wenn die flashbar sind Leute ist es
ein wirklich echt gutes Angebot, ship das aus China oder ship das aus Germany, Leute
Anzeige ist raus, die haben kein Impressum, haben die ein Impressum, aha clever, die Gosund
Deutschland hat eins, aber Gosund Deutschland hat nicht die Angebote, Pepega Kram, das gibt
nur den 2er Pack für den gleichen Preis, also hier Free Shipping, Fast Shipping, 3-5 Days,
Leute kauf ich mir nachher einen Pack, Gosund und dann gucken wir mal ob wir die flashen
können und wenn wir die nicht flashen können dann hab ich genitten, vielleicht bekommen
wir raus ob das die ESP32 Steckdosen sind, vielleicht sehen wir hier irgendwie ein, gibt
es hier ein Datenblatt oder sowas oder ein Manual oder irgendwas, nee gibt es nicht,
also man kann jetzt echt nicht erkennen ob es die ESP Steckdosen sind und noch weniger
ob die flashbar sind, das bringt dir ja nichts, du hast Templates für die, du hast Templates
für die, aber du weißt nicht ob die Hardware Revision oder generell die Hardware überhaupt
noch flashbar ist, also es gibt Templates für TASmo dafür aber das ist halt die Frage
ob du es überhaupt drauf bekommst, der Tuya App sagt ja nichts, Tuya Apps sind die alle,
was man sieht Versteckdosen gekauft hat, vermutlich nicht mehr auf TASMOTA flashbar, die Antwort
ist nein, man kann inzwischen weder OTA noch, ja gut der weiß ist halt auch nicht genau,
was, 2020 bringt ja nichts, echt, das ist bei uns auch, ja das ist Pepega, das stimmt
doch, das ist doch bestimmt alles Fake, das ist doch bestimmt alles Fake was da unten
steht Leute, das ist so diese typische China-Chinesen Chebat, das ist doch alles Chebat, das ist
doch alles Chebat, es gibt kein Thomas Mark der das gekauft hat, wisst ihr was die machen,
die machen Random Name Generator und Random Art Generator und tun so als kaufen die Leute
gerade wie verrückt, das ist Schwachsinn, das glaube ich nicht, das wird bestimmt Fake
sein, auf der anderen Seite das ist ein China-Chinesen Hersteller, da weißt du nie was die so abziehen,
die sind ja auch nicht mehr flashbar, also der Chat sagt, der hat meistens Recht, sagt
er hätte was bestellt, boop, ich kann ja mal reden, das ist vorbei, was ich sagen wollte
ist, der Chat hat eben gesagt, er hätte was bestellt und die sind noch flashbar, aber
nicht, was bringt ihr das Flashen, er hat mehrere Vorteile, du musst die offizielle
App nicht dafür verwenden um das zu steuern, du brauchst keine dauerhafte Internetverbindung,
du brauchst keine China-Chinesen Cloud um das zu betreiben, du kannst das integrieren
in deiner Heimautomatisierungslösung gescheit mit lokaler Firmware, du kannst es steuern
über ein Web-Interface, du kannst es steuern über deine Heimautomatisierung, du kannst
es steuern von jedem X-Blogging Browser aus, auch vom Handy aus, du hast Funktionen drin
die die original Firmware gar nicht kann, also es hat eigentlich nur Vorteile den Kram
zu flashen, für mich die größten Vorteile sind keine China-Chinesen Firmware und App-Zwang.
Ja, kann dir sein, dass du Glück hast, vielleicht sind die auch wieder flashbar, ich verstehe
die Hersteller eh nicht warum sie das raushauen mit dem Flashen, ganz ehrlich die Leute kaufen
sich doch jetzt nicht diese China-Steckdose, weil die denken, oh alter ich wollte schon
immer mal eine China-Steckdose haben, viele Leute sind auch in dem Bereich, gerade was
Heimautomatisierung angeht, relativ technikinteressiert und die wissen, dass man das Flashen kann
und die wollen das Flashen und wenn die das kaufen, dann wollen sie es auch flashen, was
sagst du dazu?
Aber ich sag euch übrigens gleich bevor ihr hier rumspammt, ich meine jetzt nicht dich
ja so allgemein, bevor ihr irgendwelche Ref-Links rumspammt, dann Time-Out ich euch, ich will
nicht dass ihr Ref-Links, ihr könnt Links posten und sonst was, ok, aber keine Ref-Links
und vielleicht die Session-IDs raus machen, so also was ist das, Mini PC Intel Core i5,
welcher Core i5, ist das so ein Fake-Nook oder was ist das, Ref-Link ist ein Link an den
man verdient ja, mit Ref-ID, ich sehe das gleich ob da eine drin ist, ich hab da den
Blick für, was ist das für ein i3, äh i5, ach da, lull, hab ich nicht gesehen, was dreck,
Switch-Chat, was ist hier los, was, was ist hier los, der Chat ist Massive, high IQ, was
ist das, ach das ist, ja das kenn ich, das ist, ähm, das ist der der versucht ein TAS
Motor für die neuen Chips zu programmieren, aber das ist ja noch komplett in den Anfangsschuhen,
ich nix, aber ich weiß nicht wie sinnvoll es ist Session-IDs in der UL mitzuschicken,
ja keine Ahnung was ich davon herhalte, ich kenn mich mit aktuellen Rechner-Sachen zu
wenig aus, also für 200€ würde ich sagen klingt das eigentlich durchaus brauchbar,
definitiv schneller, viel viel schneller als Raspberry Pi, unter halt x86 wenn man das
haben will, würdest du auf einem Intel-Nook ein Homelab oder ein Proxmox oder Android
verwenden, klar warum nicht, wenn es dir von der Hardware reicht, was du anschließen
kannst, warum nicht, ich für meinen Teil würde es wahrscheinlich nicht machen, ist
Scam, warum ist Scam, erklären Blitz-Chat, ähm, ich würd's nicht machen, weil Intel-Nooks
haben keine PC-Express-Slots und auch keine M2-Slots glaube ich oder zumindest keine M2-Slots
mit PC-Express, also falls du 10G reinmachen willst oder falls du irgendwie erweitern willst,
kannst du den Nook vergessen, ansonsten ja warum nicht, ehrlich gesagt, wenn es für
dich von der Hardware taugt, hau drauf, Android wirst du halt vergessen können, weil was
willst du da dran anschließen, eine interne Festplatte, fertig, mehr kriegst du ja den
Nook nicht erweitern außer über USB, man kanns doch machen, kanns doch USB Platten anschließen
und sonst geht alles, kann man alles machen, so also was kriegen wir sonst noch empfohlen,
Gosund bei Prime Day, für eine 5 Jahre alte CPU, nee 200 Euro soll man bezahlen hat der
Chat gesagt, nicht 400, 400 find ich auch zu teuer, aber für 200 scheint mir das ganz
ok zu sein, Gosund, so viel Gosund hier, was denn das, Alexa-Sternenhimmel-Projektor,
die haben aber auch alles oder, auch Dinger von denen ich von der Existenz bis jetzt noch
nix wusste, ein Alexa-Sternenhimmel-Projektor, was macht man mit einem, also ich mein mir
ist klar damit projiziert man einen Sternenhimmel, aber will man sowas haben, schau mal was
es für Raspberry Pis gibt, wahrscheinlich keine und wenn zu teuer, oder meinst du jetzt
irgendwie Addons oder so, Sensoren, die Sensoren sind doch eh so billig, da musst du nicht
im Prime Day kaufen, die meisten Sensoren kosten 2, 3 Euro und dann schon im 5er Pack, Montana
Black findet sowas krass wegen Ambiente, ja aber Montana Black hat sicherlich kein 37
Euro, eh, Gosund-Sternenhimmel-Projektor, sondern irgendwie sowas total übertrieben
teures für 85.000 Euro, der irgendwie den gesamten Sternen-Katalog von sonst was mit
eingebaut hat, gibt es eine gescheite, smarte Steckdose für Homo-System im Angebot, bin
ich gerade am gucken, also das Gosund Zeug kann man halt wahrscheinlich nicht mehr flashen
und dementsprechend sackt es, next, brau man alles nicht, brau man nicht, brau man nicht,
brau man nicht, brau man nicht, was das, USB, ah ok, Adapter, Netzwerk, brau man nicht,
brau man nicht, brau man nicht, brau man nicht, brau man nicht, so nächste Seite, brau
man nicht, guck mal die Seite lädt schon gar nicht mehr, brau man nicht, brau man nicht,
brau man nicht, ok, crap, next, Amazon Basics, hast du ein Link zum Sorge im Hintergrund,
ja, nein nicht der Lindner, was macht der Lindner da, das ist die Mario 64 Musik, wenn
die Piranha Pflanze schläft, ok die machen alle Werbung, das sollte ich jetzt auch mal
machen, brau, brau, brau, muss ich auch irgendwie sowas reinhauen, Epic New Battlefield 3 Mod,
Leute, richtig Clickbait Titel brauchen wir dafür, dieser Mod, also dieser Mod wird dein
Leben verändern ist langweilig, weil die Leute haben mittlerweile gecheckt, dass diese
Videotitel nicht funktionieren, heute musste die Leute anders baiten, Amazon Basics Kleiner
Bügel, Pog, Amazon Basics Handtücher, Amazon Basics hat auch wirklich alles, vom Pflaster
bis zum Kondom bis zum Wäschetrockner, alles Amazon Basics, oh das, Alter, das ist ein
Massive Titel, das ist gut, der Titel hat zwar mit der Realität nichts zu tun, aber
der Titel, den finde ich wirklich gut, dieser Mod wird von Dice verboten, weil er so gut
ist oder so, was überhaupt nicht stimmt, aber das ist ja bei Clickbait nebensächlich, ob
es stimmt, solange es in Funke Wahrheit hat, dass man sich irgendwie rausreden kann, ist
das alles in Ordnung, ist das eine Hängematte, es gibt eine Amazon Basics Hängematte, Besen,
Schirme, Vakuum Verpackungen, Vox, Safes, Kissen, Schraubenschlüssel, Dinger, wo ich
keine Ahnung habe, was ist, Muffin, Förmchen oder sowas, Plastikdosen, es gibt, Alter,
das ist ein Safe, Schüssel, Betten, Töpfe, Handtücher, Matratzen, Alter, 11 Seiten Amazon
Basics, ernsthaft, ne, das wäre jetzt zu viel Amazon Basics, Dice möchte nicht, dass
du diesen Mod kennst, ja, das ist auch, Leute, ich sehe, ich sehe, ich muss euch öfters
fragen, was Titel angeht, ich muss euch öfters fragen, der Chat weiß Bescheid, okay genug
Amazon Basics geguckt, Safe on Samsung, Sekunde Leute, ich muss mal kurz Licht einschalten
hier und das Gute ist, wisst ihr, ich muss zum Licht einschalten, nicht mal mehr aufstehen,
ich gehe jetzt auf den zweiten Bildschirm in mein Home Assistant rein und mache jetzt
einen Klick und zack, ist mein Licht an der Decke an, so muss das sein, das hat Hauptsatz
und Nebensatz, das ist schon wieder zu high IQ für YouTube Titel, stimmt auch wieder,
weiss hast diesen Trick, ne, das ist ausgelutscht, das kennen die Leute schon, also M2 SSDs, SSDs,
cool, das ist Samsung SSDs, interessiert mich jetzt nicht, Fritz, Moment, Netgear, was genau,
sag mal, Sekunde, mein Rechner ist übelst ausgelastet, was ist hier denn los, ich muss
mal kurz, muss mal kurz schauen, was hier mein Rechner so auslastet, der ist laggy,
was lastet mein Rechner so aus, nix, Chet, lasst mal euer Hackerman Kram sein hier, wer
von euch ist es, wer ist schon wieder drin hier, ich, ja, fünf Leute gleichzeitig, streiten
sich gerade, wer zuerst den Keylogger deploit, dieses vier Fenstersymbol unten links könnte
das Problem sein, das da, ja, das stimmt, das ist wahrscheinlich das Problem, das ist
ja eigentlich auch das falsche Logo, das richtige Logo ist ja das hier, also Microsoft
weiß selber nicht, wie ihr Windows Logo aussieht, das ist in Wirklichkeit das richtige Windows
Logo, Continuous Integration für den Keylogger läuft schon, so mag ich das, der agile DevOps
Ansatz hat sich durchgesetzt, also Netgear und Co. und da gibt es erstmal nur Fritzbox
Stinger, ok, nice, GG Ease, Ease, Netgear, Fritzbox, was, was ist das, ah, ein WLAN,
WLAN Mobile, WLAN LTE Router, alter den Crap braucht doch echt niemand.
Also Tender hört sich irgendwie an, wie eine Damenbinde weniger als nach einem Accesspoint,
und was benutzt du so, hm, meine Tender, aber es hört sich nicht so nicht technisch
an, Orbi kommt jetzt als nächstes, der Orbi, der Orbi, war das nicht in Black Ops, der
Blackboard im nächsten Black Ops, war das nicht der Orbi, Black Ops 2, ja, der Orbi
ist am Start, next, alter warum ist, das liegt am Darkreader, warum der Scheiß so langsam
ist, ich sags euch, guckt euch das mal an, Flashbang, die Dinger sehen auch immer abgedrehter
aus, das Teil, alter, oh man, so USB, ist ja alles Müll, braucht doch keiner, was genau
hat es mit den restlichen Sachen zu tun, ach das ist ein WiFi, ein WiFi Bilderrahmen,
690 Euro, warum kann ich mir den nicht einfach in Amazon Tablet an die Wand hängen und da
ein Bild drauf anzeigen lassen, also dann doch lieber für 50 Euro sich ein Amazon Tablet
kaufen, das ist wahrscheinlich, na ok, das ist nicht 41 mal 61, das ist schon ein bisschen
größer, das ist Bilderrahmen SSService, ja wahrscheinlich, wenn du die Cloud App von
denen nicht verwendest, gehts nicht, und nach einem halben Jahr stellen sie den Service ein
und du kannst deinen Bilderrahmen nicht mehr benutzen, ich wette mit euch, du musst, das
gucken wir uns jetzt an, ich wette mit euch, du musst die offizielle App dafür verwenden,
anders geht es gar nicht, ihre Kunstsammlung ist jetzt endlos, ja die Leute sammeln die
Dinger ja nicht, weil sie die auf dem digitalen Bilderrahmen anzeigen lassen wollen, das bestimmt
eine proprietäre App, App, mit einer App bei Netgear, ich weiß nicht, ob das so das Qualitätsmerkmal
ist, Moral App, die Moral App, da müssen wir jetzt gucken, ok, schau mal beschissene
Bewertung, alles klar, nee, Moment, ganz gute Bewertung, das ist die richtige, Moral, oh
es supporte NFT Items, ho, da bin ich aber beruhigt, hab schon gedacht, ich kann da meine
NFTs nicht drauf anzeigen, bin ich aber froh, dass mein Bilderrahmen NFT Support hat, nochmal
saved, saved, ich weiß, wenn man den Leuten jetzt erzählt, dass man die NFT Bilder darauf
auch anzeigen kann, ohne dass man die NFTs besitzt, was machen sie dann?
Noch mehr Amazon Basics, diesmal ist es ein Taker und ein Dokumentenvernichter, eine Laptoptasche
und Batterien und Marker und Bleistift und Batterien und Noise Canceling Headphones von
S-Rhythm, ach nee, S-Rhythm, ok, man muss das auch richtig, richtig lesen, Crap, Crap,
ich hab keinen Bock, ok, what the fuck, Exit Page, oh, ach so, das Ding, das hatten wir
doch schon, ok, weiter, glaub der Dark Reader, der Dark Reader macht wirklich gerade den Abgang,
oh, oh, Chet, warum geht man Virenscanner so hoch, was macht ihr da wieder, was, was
ist da wieder los, so was haben wir denn sonst noch, also gucken wir mal, Mobile-Dings-Probleme,
so ein Device, das haben wir ja schon geguckt, Computer, Electronics, ok, auf geht's, ist
jetzt beim Deploy-Step angekommen, ach deswegen, ja, dann versteh ich's, richtig, richtig
agiles Mindset-Chat, habt ihr gut gemacht, aus Indien, die die sonst auch für den Microsoft-Gold-Support
arbeiten, wir sind bestimmt die gleichen, ok, Müll, Müll, Müll, hatten die nicht mal
eine Smart-Home-Kategorie, die hatten wir eine Smart-Home-Kategorie, die es aber irgendwie
nicht mehr gibt, ok, schnell durchgegangen, Müll, Müll, Müll, Müll, Müll, alles Müll,
Artefake, Artefake, ok, er war ja schon ganz ganz sehr gut, nonprofit.
zauerei was ein krasser chibate oder erstes was mich interessiert gibt es nicht tp link
du hast jetzt zwei fire tv sticks geholt sonstig was machst du damit mit den fire ich finde
den fire tv stick laggy schau pass auf was kommt was kommt jetzt was für ein ding ovo
malteine crunchy cream brotaufstrich ohne palmöl ja dafür mit zeug ist das ist das pock
ist das pock ich kenne das nicht das zeug ist pock oder not pock pock ja was sagt ihr
versus versus nutella kennst du youtube werbung nicht nö ist es ist es pock ok
crunchy
wenn es aus das war aus der schweiz kommt dann taugt es die ich will kein abo guck mal
amazon wieder die wollen mir ein ernsthaft ein brotaufstrich aber verkaufen ein one time
purchase kein abo uu habe ich noch nie gehört chat bin ich nicht auf dem aktuellen stand aber
jetzt kenne ich es auch brotaufstrich aber ja aber gucken wir jetzt nicht moment wo
sind wir stehen geblieben ah hier so müll müll müll brauchen wir nicht müll next rasenmeer
die rasenmeer brauche ich auch nicht unsinnig unsinnig unsinnig es gibt es gibt echt es ist
wieder es ist für soviel so viel müll ich weiß auch nicht irgendwie
wer kauft rasenmeer bei amazon ich würde rasenmeer bei amazon kaufen was jetzt passiert
ich habe health und beauty angeklickt wollte ich ja gar nicht ich würde rasenmeer bei amazon kaufen
gar kein problem ich habe leute ich habe sogar autoreifen bei amazon gekauft
der witz hat jetzt auch schon es war auch gab auch schon lustigere comments was ist denn
technisat irgendein uraltes label für fernseher mal mein opa hatte früher was von technisat
das weiß ich noch also mir ist unklar also ich wusste bis jetzt nicht mehr dass es das
überhaupt noch gibt technisat das ist sowas wie was es früher sonst noch gab so grundig
und und und sonstige dinger was jetzt ich ist es nicht so grundig gehört in irgendeinem
türkischen laden und und technisat was weiß ich 1987 gekündigt ja sag ich doch ich sag
mein opa hatte auch so dinger technisat telefunken gab es auch noch stimmt nee sorry leute telefunken
hatte der telefunken nicht technisat das habe ich durcheinander geschmissen oder nee der
hatte doch der hatte ein dvbt empfänger von technisat das ist auch sowas alter mein opa
ja da hat es teilweise auch ganz schön verkackt der hat mich gefragt was soll ich mir kaufen
ja also der wollte fernseh gucken der hat fernseh geguckt analog über antenne und irgendwie
haben die dann analog über antenne abgeschaltet und dann wollte er weiter fernseh gucken und
er hat gesagt aha was soll ich also was soll ich jetzt kaufen und ich habe gesagt opa entweder
du lässt endlich mal einen kabelanschluss ins haus legen was der damals nicht wollte
was uns jetzt saumäßig viel geld gekostet hat oder du holst die satellitenschüssel lass
dvbt sein krab gerade am anfang was hat er gemacht er hat nicht auf mich gehört er ist
in einen lokalen elektronikladen gegangen hat sich einen technisat receiver gekauft
und hatte über dvbt geguckt und das hat permanent rumgeruckelt und dann hat er mich immer gefragt
so nach dem motto ha der fernseh geht nicht kannst du mal gucken
ja oma kauft ihr eine satellitenschüssel den weißen hintergrund ist ganz einfach wie
ich mir das mit dem weißen hintergrund geben kann weil der dark reader auf amazon einfach
den kompletten browser den kompletten rechner load
ne blink ist müll würde ich mir nie kaufen an kameras genauso wie ich mir auch nie eins
von diesen komischen türklingeln kaufen würde die nur mit abgehen das muss alles über rtsp
oder irgendwie zumindest mal emotion jpeg oder sonst was über irgendwas normales abrufbar
sein natürlich rtsp mit einem h264 stream am besten und dann ist gut alles andere ist
dreck ring ist genauso müll kommt mir in ihm lebe nicht ins haus
habe ich heute werbung gesehen auf twitter da hat irgendeine firma ihren blog post beworben
so nach dem motto wie können wir das internet of things sicherer machen mal gucken ob ich
das noch finde
tweets and replies steht das da
ja guck mal hier haben irgendwie werbung gemacht hier wie können wir das internet of things
sicherer machen vor der bedrohung schützen leute die einfachste variante ist ein smart
home shit nicht ins internet stellen aber das wollen die hersteller nicht die hersteller
wollen wenn du log in bei der smartphone app die hersteller wollen irgendwelche komischen
proprietären cloud geschichten die wollen dass du das ding nicht autonomen dass du das
ding vor ort ansprechen kannst die wollen auch nicht dass du sind irgendwelche smart
home lösungen integriert die nicht ihre sind die wollen dass du ihren scheiß benutzt mit
always on und china chinesen cloud also es ist jetzt nicht so als wüsste man nicht was
man dagegen machen kann die wollen da bloß nichts dagegen machen
deswegen flashe ich ja auch alles was flaschbar ist und was nicht flaschbar ist kommt in meinen
china chinesen wlan was nirgends wohin darf weder ins internet das einzige was man china
chinesen wlan da fürs ntp machen auf meinen router das aber auch das auch komplett alles
und geräte die gar nicht lokal kommunizieren die kaufe ich mir gar nicht
es ist so viel überflüssiger müll dabei mama ruft an save und wo davon ohje ich ahne
schlimmes kann man diese show me waage flaschen nein nicht direkt aber die musst du auch nicht
flaschen also meinst du die ich habe also meinst hier die da du meinst diese waage
also warum ist das
da kann die seite mal funktionieren please
du meinst diese war die seite ist total überlastet da geht nichts
seite müde seite schlafen du meinst diese waage hier also die kannst du nicht flaschen
aber die musst du auch nicht flaschen weil die waage kann ihre wie grugen per bluetooth
also kann man die abfragen die waage schickt die sachen e per bluetooth raus und die kannst
du mit jedem x beliebigen esp 32 abgreifen die musst du nicht flaschen ich glaube du
kannst die noch nicht mal ins internet packen die waage du kannst die höchsten sparen mit
der offiziellen app und das dann auslesen musst du aber nicht die geht auch so per bluetooth
ja die kann auch körperfettanteil warum machst du das immer mit der 1 weil ich mir das angewöhnt
habe total unsinnig nicht nachmachen oder sich nicht angewöhnen so also was kann ich
denn auch ein vodafone saufen die vodafone smartwatch ich weiß ja nicht ich will eh keine
smartwatch aber eine smartwatch von vodafone glaubt noch weniger oppo ist billiger hammer
ist billiger bontech ist billiger kabel direkt ist billiger na dann vielleicht sind das echt
paar ganz praktische verlängerungs sachen dabei perl smith habe ich noch nie gehört
ist aber auch billiger amazon hat echt alles mittlerweile pumpen billiger bayern münchen
fanartikel billiger meine güte ist aber nix dabei was ich habe apc ok gucken wir mal
gibt es vielleicht paar sinnvolle us v vielleicht hole ich mir dann doch mal wieder eine batterien
billiger doando günstiger ob das was taugt das ist bestimmt irgend so ein china chinesen
hersteller von perreferie die versuchen krass auszusehen aber von der hardware her halt
sachen
ja barbie bei ich habs gesehen ich gette den witz nicht so ganz
wassapp sim weil die haben simkarten ich war heute in einer eis stile eis essen und
die hatten allen ernstes wassapp eis kein spaß ich habe ja auch noch mal habe ich jetzt
richtig gesehen daneben gab es barbie eis und bine maya eis und alles mögliche und irgendwo
zwischendrin wassapp eis ja weird champ weiß ich nicht was das schmeckt ich habe mir das
nicht geholt zwar grün wassapp eis kurz gucken ob ich wassapp eis ob man das findet da findest
der jetzt natürlich sonst was
ja wassapp eis gabs ich verstehe nicht warum wir gigabit verträge haben sollten nicht
alles unlimited sein tja wir sind in deutschland also nicht so easy mit internet sachen ich
mein unlimited muss ja nicht sein aber wenn sich das in regionen abspielt wo du eigentlich
bedenkenlos surfen kannst ist alles ok es gibt ja mittlerweile verträge die ganz ok
sind und das ist tatsächlich die letzten jahre über sehr viel besser geworden ich habe ja
noch vor drei vier jahren das übelste oder vier fünf jahre schon bisschen übelste rent
video gemacht über kak handy verträge mittlerweile ist es besser
ne das ist nicht die eisdiele in der ich heute war bei der eisdiele wo ich heute war war
vorne das schild whatsapp und es hatte sogar ein selbstgemaltes whatsapp logo auf dem schild
drauf und stand whatsapp eis
brauche man nicht brauche man auch alles nicht
acer notebooks könnte man vielleicht gebrauchen brauche ich nicht
ryzen brauche ich jetzt auch nicht mehr
hp ok da steht hp ja aber auf dem bild sieht man rocket logitech und kosa was auch immer
das mit hp zu tun hat
razor nicht rocket richtig ihr habt recht chat chat halt wieder richtig high iq messig
drauf einfach giga chat der chat heute wieder auch unsinnig unsinnig unsinnig unsinnig unsinnig
fahrradhelm ok nicht unsinnig aber brauche ich nicht
das kommt mir was war denn minis das sagt mir irgendwas minis forum da klingelt irgendwas
im hinterkopf ich kann es nicht mehr genau zuordnen sagt euch minis forum was irgendwie
kommt mir der name bekannt vor
der bauer das was mit dem bauer zu tun
13 monate kann sein dass ich von denen was gesehen habe auf youtube aber irgendwie sagt
mir das was für ein handy vertrag ich habe kann ich dir nicht sagen ich habe ein iphone
von der firma wo ich arbeite mit einem vertrag von der firma wo ich arbeite also ich hab
gibt es irgendwo eine webseite von der telekom wo man irgendwas von der telekom ist es wo
man nachgucken kann
die telekom vertrag und wenn ich auf die seite gehe aus dem telekom netz dann sehe ich was
ich habe
wenn ihr mir sagt wo das wo das
mit der magent in die stelle mir keine magenta ab jetzt pass punkt telekom punkt e alles
klar pass punkt telekom punkt de
informationen für den aufruf dieser seite ist ein internetverbindung über das mobilfunknetz
bla bla bla
achso moment muss ich wählen ausschalten
also ich habe your telekom data plan 20 gigabyte im monat
habe ich
das steht aber nicht dabei wie der vertrag heißt
kann ich euch jetzt auch nicht sagen 20 gigabyte ja also nicht 20 gigabyte verbraucht sondern
20 gigabyte ist darf ich monatlich verbrauchen
schon wieder obi dokumenten ordner
was ist das
ist das ein lüfter
erkennt ihr das ist das ein lüfter
ein ventilator mit ab
er ist ganz wichtig für den ventilator dass der eine app hat
wie könnte man nur einen ventilator ohne app bedienen
unglaublich wie geht das nur hexenwerk
der zoomer der zoomer ventilator das braucht eine app sonst geht das nicht
lgb ram wichtig
mehr frames lgb ram ist tatsächlich an dem moment
nicht lgb ne doch lgb ram und lgb m2 ssd
habt ihr led strips ja
relativ
ne und eine unterboden belichtung habe ich nicht
ich habe led strips eben hier im fenster
ich habe led strips wo habe ich denn überhaupt alles welche
überlegen wo habe ich led ich habe alles mit wled selbst gebaut
also an der treppe für die beleuchtung habe ich
hier am fenster habe ich
unten in der kirche am fenster habe ich für den weihnachtsbaum habe ich aber das kein
led strip das ist so eine so eine kette aber halt auch mit wled zum ansteuern
ich glaube das war es
ich habe das anders gemacht ich habe die strips in so einen diffusor gemacht
und den dann ans fenster geklebt
welche led strips nutzt du da das kann ich dir aus dem kopf nicht sagen ich glaube sk6
ok warte led sk so was da
glaube
die könnten das sein bin ich mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz sicher
es sind auf jeden fall welche mit weiß dabei
und ich steuere das ja das ist überhaupt was ist ein steuerbar ich mache das ich steuere
das alles mit wled
wled ist ziemlich hog ich kann euch zeigen wie das aussieht
sag muss man nur die ip raussuchen von dem teil
einstellungen integrationen wled
so sieht das aus bei mir
die wled version ist übrigens auch uralt gehe ich mal von aus hier
da kannst du hier oben einstellen welche farbe du haben willst
da kannst du noch einstellen sättigung und und helligkeit und gedöns
da kannst du einstellen ob du effekte haben willst
ich habe zum beispiel den multi candle effekt dann flackert das so leicht aber halt jede
jede led ein bisschen anders
das ist das ist das ist das was ich an der treppe hab
oh nein ip leak schon wieder
ah jetzt ist jetzt ist
erst hacker man meinen browser alarm gelegt und jetzt auch bald noch mein led strip
sieht das dann so aus wie bei ich weiß nicht wer das ist
ja also das ist nice
turbo dead end danke schön für den sub danke leute für die ganzen subs heute ich hab bestimmt
wieder die hälfte übersehen
ja das mein led strip let's go
das kann passieren das passiert folgendermaßen wenn du led strips kaufst die nur rgb haben
und nicht rgbw wenn du led strips hast die also es gibt bei led strips eigentlich zwei
grundsätzliche unterschiede es gibt welche mit drei farben und welche mit vier farben
vier farben ist ganz normal rgb
er drei farben ist ganz normal rgb und vier farben ist rgb plus weiß hat den vorteil und
dann kann man meistens dieses strips noch in unterschiedlichen weiß tönen kaufen der
vorteil ist dass weiß bei diesen leds auch wirklich weiß ist
und ansonsten wenn die blau sind gibt es verschiedene varianten entweder hast du rgb vertauscht also
dass es dann vielleicht gar nicht rgb ist sondern bg ra oder gbr oder sowas oder aber
das mischen von allen farben kommt halt auf den bläulichen ton raus und dann musst du
es halt so so justieren dass es dass es die passende farbe gibt
ja was es gibt auch rgb y was ist denn y ich mein rot grün blau ok weiß und was ist y
yellow ah das ist dass du den weiß ton selbst einstellen kannst oder wie das ist natürlich
ganz clever
ich habe schon gesehen kann ich kann ich mich trauen nee achja naja gesehen nicht können
wir uns gucken wir uns gucken wir uns gleich noch an zusammen ich verfolge die schon seit
jahren auf discord das projekt ja keine benutzen ich hatte auch eine lange zeit habe ich sogar
mal im stream gezeigt aber ich muss ehrlich sagen ich verstehe den sinn nicht für start
pages keine benutzen browser bookmarks machen fertig wozu brauchst du start pages ich habe
mir auch eine gemacht einfach weil es cool aussieht für das video wo ich es mal gezeigt
habe aber ansonsten ich verstehe den sinn von start pages nicht bookmarks im browser
fertig geht schneller brauchst du keine extra seite ja ok wenn es für mehrere leute sind
ja homer habe ich auch verwendet gibt es aber massig verschiedene dashboard sachen ja ok
wenn du es mit für mehrere verwendest dann verstehe ich das ja aber intern weiß nicht
ok wenn man von ja verstehe ich auch leuchte mir ein wenn man von außen drauf zugreift
ok ja sind alles anwendungsszenarien die habe ich nicht aber das verstehe ich ja ein portable
fan i wish an e wish oh ja das klingt ja definitiv nach einer maus die ich haben möchte i wish
ane wish noiseless klick ach das ist fürs tablet ein fernklaas ich wollte mir wirklich
letztens in fernklaas fernklaas kaufen aber ich gehe davon aus dass dieses fernklaas
was hier bei amazon ist wahrscheinlich sacken wird das ist doch china bea bang be bang das
ist china kram wobei ich meine das ist ja im prinzip nur ein klaas also vielleicht können
die china chinesen das warum kann ich dir erklären nicht was die leute jetzt wieder
sagen so nach dem motto null max du willst irgendwo reingucken oder sonst was zum beispiel
wenn ich wandern gehe frage ich mich öfters mal was ist das denn da was ich da in der
entfernung sehe zum beispiel in irgendwelche gebäude wenn ich für die nachdenklich kann
es nicht genau erkennen und da habe ich mir schon öfters überlegt ich sollte mir vielleicht
mal fernklaas mitnehmen ein wandern korrekt ich war fenster oma fenster boomer also wenn
ihr demnächst in hanau einen am fenster stehen seht mit fernklaas der so aussieht dann bin
ich das
oma face usfaus stimmt usfaus wollte ich gucken haben wir noch ein paar aufgemacht hier es
gibt usfaus der hersteller soll er laut chat ganz gut sein qnap juckt mich nett wo habe
ich denn die eher oma usfaus also ok das ist alles keine rekbauweise das wäre aber auch
nicht schlimm
ja die in rek rek form gibt es natürlich nicht aber trotzdem haben die ein usb anschluss
oder sind die unmanaged oder wie nennt man das bei usfaus die sind komplett an nee die
haben usb die haben einen kleinen webserver mit drinne das stelle ich mir merkwürdig
das stelle ich mir komisch vor wenn die was internet mode wollte gerade sagen die haben
doch gar kein netzwerkanschluss aber doch die haben wir netzwerkanschluss leute chat
taugen die ich meine jetzt nicht von der ich nicht von der leistung her das reicht für
meinen schrank locker aus und viel wichtiger wenn der strom an ist und die batterie kaputt
geht bleibt es dann an ich weiß nicht ich glaube ich bleib weiter ohne usf ich hab bisher
nur negative erfahrungen im heimbereich mit usfaus bei mir ist mehr durch die usf kaputt
gegangen als ohne usf kaputt gegangen wäre
anker es gibt ja wirklich nix ne es gibt einfach nix also nix was irgendwie sich für mich
lohnen würde hallo möchtest schließen please schließen schließen ok na guck ich doch mal
schnell smart home durch du hättest eine smarte klingel ich würde aber nicht die smarten
klingeln kaufen mit app zwang und vendor log in was willst du als smarte klingel haben
willst du nur eine klingel wo du auf dem handy mitbekommst wenn es geklingelt hat das ließe
sich ziemlich easy nachrüsten oder willst du eine klingel die wirklich bild streamt
und du mit dem typ sprechen kannst übers handy dann wird es schwieriger dann brauchst
du wahrscheinlich was neues ja benachrichtigung aufs handy ist einfach dass das da gibt es
sehr viele möglichkeiten das zu machen also die einfachste variante ohne dass du an der
dass du da ohne dass du an die verkabelung dran muss ist du machst den sp 32 sp 82 66
controller an die an an die klingel oder an das telefon wo es klingelt mit einem sensor
der eben checkt wenn es besonders laut ist daneben das funktioniert eigentlich ganz
gut wenn man wirklich gar nicht eingreifen darf in die verkabelung das geht relativ einfach
und falls du die 5 volt für den sp anzapfen kann es natürlich noch besser wenn du wenn
du an die verkabelung dran kannst dann kann man vielleicht noch mehr machen aber das einfachste
ist tatsächlich microcontroller dran mit so einem mikrofon sensor der dich dann benachrichtigt
wenn es geklingelt hat das ist relativ einfach zu machen
und ich habe gar keinen bock weiter zu weiter zu scrollen weil es eh nichts gibt ein senioren
telefon sowas hatte ich meinem opa mal gekauft vor langer zeit
raspberry pi starter kit aha es gibt ein raspberry pi nee es gibt kein raspberry pi
es gibt eine überteuerte teile sammlung für ein raspberry pi ja gut das braucht keiner
ja würde ich auch näher abrennen wird davon nichts aber das kannst du machen ja also dann
ist das beste was ich gesagt habe du machst einen microcontroller mit einem mikrofon
sensor hin da musst du halt nur gucken wo du den strom anschließt wenn du es nicht
von der anlage abzapfen kannst und der kann dich benachrichtigen so musst du nicht in
die verkabelung eingreifen wozu benutzt ihr eure raspberry pies also ich habe aktuell
im einsatz einen raspberry pi 4 unten im wohnzimmer mit ssd dran da lief früher der unify controller
drauf aber ich habe kein unify mehr deswegen brauche ich den controller nicht aktuell
läuft da bloß was für die für das streaming von den überwachungs kameras drauf das kommt
aber weg der ist überhaupt nicht ausgelassen ziemlich unsinnig da habe ich ein raspberry
pie im keller stehen der ließ daten von der also da hatte ich früher den pico w dran
hängen aber den habe ich abgelöst durch den richtig echten raspberry pie und der ließ
die daten von der heizung aus und kann auch die heizung den heizungsstatus ändern der
guckt ob es geklingelt hat mit einem analog digital konverter ließ da aus eben die spanung
von der klingel ob es geklingelt hat ja und sende das an die heim automatisierung und
dann habe ich noch ein raspberry pie am 3d drucker zum sketches uploaden und druck anstoßen
und sowas alle anderen habe ich mittlerweile wieder abgebaut im wohnzimmer den raspberry
pie für fernsehaufnahmen habe ich ersetzt durch so eine linux box aber auch mit tv
headend ja und hier neben mir habe ich noch zwei raspberry pies vier liegen zwei raspberry
pies vier liegen im flea case gibt es vielleicht in flea case günstig das wäre natürlich
cool aber das gibt es naftos also ganz ehrlich für 10 euro scheint mir das in ordnung zu
gehen der label champ nöder ist immer noch nicht fertig lull ganz schön teuer
champ moment das ist ein touch screen im gehäuse das ist eigentlich eine ganz praktische sache
wenn man dafür ein anwendungsszenario hat so was trug man sich ich bin gespannt wie
du dir ein alu gehäuse drucken willst long runa das ist die gleiche kamera die schon
seit jetzt gefühlt zehn jahren für raspberry pie gibt nur jetzt mit zum komischen objektiv
drauf fischermanns freund raspberry ich wollte gerade sagen warum zum teufel findet er fischermanns
freund wenn ich da raspberry sucht aber weil raspberry raspberry geschmack was heißt
raspberry auf deutsch eigentlich noch mal himbeere ist das himbeere ich bin gerade auf
dem schlauch raspberry pie zero case ja himbeere ok ja besser wäre es wenn es ein raspberry
pie wäre und nicht nur das case i unicare an dem namen steht einfach schon china chinesen
zeug dran netac mikro sd hat irgendjemand von euch schon mal von netac was gehört ich
noch nie bestimmt ein äußerst renommierter hersteller für mikro sd karten pinheader
auf pinheader habe ich angst mittlerweile ich hatte jetzt schon zweimal pinheader im fuß
stecken was kann der mikro pie eigentlich leisten du meinst du den pico den pico oder
was denn ja gar nichts das ist kein raspberry pie das ja ein microcontroller der ist ganz
ehrlich ich verstehe nicht warum irgendjemand raspberry pie pico verwenden will esp 32
der normale ist einfach in allen belangen besser verstehe ich nicht auch das entwickeln
ich habe es letztens ausprobiert leute ich habe ich habe ich habe mir zwei pico picos
pico wege gekauft du hast die auswahl zwischen c only mit ihrem komischen sdk was nix unterstützt
oder platform i o arduino der aber auch nix unterstützt weil so die minimalst basic arduino
implementierung ist also komplett sinnlos ich würde nur esp 32 verwenden was ist das
an kühlen passivkühler ja das verkauft sich auch nur weil es raspberry pie heißt ansonsten
verstehe ich den anwendungszweck für den pico echt nicht crunchy protein bar auf geht's
ein guter tag ja ist leider kein raspberry pie dabei hast du schon was gefunden nee
nur müll doch ich habe mir zwei picos gekauft wie gesagt ich habe es ausprobiert auf dem
einen und ich verstehe nicht warum man die verwenden sollte wenn man noch einfach ganz
normale esp 32 verwenden kann die als d1 mini ausführung ähnlich klein sind und sogar
noch ein ticken günstiger andere frage warum arbeiten wir alle und tun so schlau ich weiß
nicht wir sind schlau chat wir tun doch nicht nur schlau oder ich dachte immer durch die
ganzen subs sind wir mittlerweile wirklich schlau und und müssen das nicht mal faken
wie high iq chat ja also tun so schlau obwohl wir schon die technik hätten das robot und
der eis alles für uns machen können also ich bezweifle dass wir die technik hätten
das robot und eis alles machen können du siehst es aber in bereichen wo man das machen
kann ja also das was früher fließbandarbeit war irgendwelche autostraßen und sonst was
da wird ja vermehrt was von robot und eis gemacht und wenn du nach japan guckst da sind
ja auch deutlich weiter was solche techniken angeht deutscher sind wir noch ein bisschen
hinten dran aber das wird jetzt kommen man sieht es jetzt schon und es ist davon auszugehen
dass viele berufe die es jetzt noch gibt also bin ich mir ziemlich sicher viele berufe
die es jetzt noch gibt ist jetzt die letzte generation die die jemals ausüben wird und
dann werden zwar nicht robot und eis alles machen aber das was sich eben lohnt zu automatisieren
wird gemacht werden und es wird in anderen bereichen arbeitsplätze schaffen und insgesamt
aber mehr verlieren als dass es neue schafft ich meine ist ja ganz einfach ja wenn du sagen
wir mal zehn fließbandarbeiter durch eine robot greifarm ersetzt dann brauchst du
vielleicht zwei programmierer zu zehn fließbandarbeiter also ja die brauchst du mehr du hast quasi
ein arbeits du hast quasi zwei arbeitsplätze geschaffen für zwei programmierer oder techniker
aber zehn sind weg quickmaps also es werden insgesamt auf jeden fall weniger und da bin
ich immer gespannt wie wir das handeln wollen wenn die dann alle in renter gehen und unser
rentensystem jetzt schon nicht richtig funktioniert und wenn die auf einmal alle in renter gehen
in was weiß ich 10 15 jahren da bin ich echt mal gespannt das kann hinten das wird wahrscheinlich
hinten vorne nix aber gut dass ich meine stonks habe ai zum programmieren nutzen wir
verlieren ja das wird nicht passieren zumindest nicht in absehbarer zeit natürlich kann man
sich jetzt das scenario ausmalen was passiert wenn dann auch irgendwann mal programmierer
durch ai ersetzt werden und die ai selbst ai programmiert ob wir uns dann nicht in
richtung terminator oder so entwickeln also das halte ich jetzt zum aktuellen zeitpunkt
irgendwie noch für ziemlich zusammen konstruiert aber dass man in zukunft ai verwenden wird
um ai sachen zu verbessern das kann ich mir gut vorstellen und wir haben die letzten jahre
wirklich richtig krasse fortschritte gemacht guckt euch mal an was wir für tools haben
die man früher gar nicht für möglich gehalten hat ja du hast ai ist die aus musikstücken
die instrumente extrahieren können du hast ai ist die bilder freistellen können für
dich du hast ai ist die elemente in bildern entfernen kann du hast ai ist die ich sag
es jetzt weil das das ist wo ihr alle dran denkt wo du leute drin naggisch machen kannst
du hast du hast ai ist wo du bilder beschreibungen dir holen kannst in textform also sprich
du gibst ja ein bild die ai sagt dir was auf dem bild zu sehen ist was relativ gut funktioniert
und wenn es halt nicht funktioniert ist es komplett falsch ja aber meistens ist es relativ
gut also wir haben sehr viele sachen in dieser richtung und da ist in die letzten zehn jahren
fünf jahren ist da also die letzten fünf jahre reicht da schon wenn ihr das anguckt
enorm viel passiert ja sollen sie mal machen personalabteilung braucht eh keiner
das ist der vorteil von ai ist den ist es egal ob sie cobalt programmieren oder nicht
ja ich weiß nutzt jemand copilot ja ich weiß dass viele im chat sogar copilot nutzen zumindest
immer wenn es um das thema geht haben wir hier leute die was dazu schreiben ich verwende
kein copilot was mich abschreckt ist dass es jetzt auch was kostet ja es gibt laufend
auf aufrufe github zu verlassen die haben auch github schon verlassen als es microsoft
gekauft hat das hat glaube ich kein projekt was es getan und was es gemacht hat wirklich
gut getan was ist copilot copilot ist ein eine ai die dir beim programmieren hilft ihr
macht vorschläge was du als nächstes schreiben möchtest also wenn du zum beispiel schreibst
in deinem text editor class und dann drückst du autocomplete für copilot dann schlägt
dir dann beispielsweise vor a kontextbasiert du willst jetzt eine klasse anlegen person
mit vor und nachname drin und sowas richtig richtig genau ist es ist fast das gleiche
wobei ich halt sagen muss whatsapp gibt es halt wirklich dinger die ich richtig kacke
finde warum ich auch nicht verwende aber bei github ist es eigentlich immer noch eine
gute plattform ja microsoft hat den kram übernommen und microsoft baut immer noch
viel scheiße und wird auch immer viel scheiße bauen aber microsoft hat die letzten jahre
über auch paar gute sachen gemacht angefangen von mischel studio code und auch github haben
sie nicht komplett verkackt wsl ist auch ok wobei das natürlich bei microsoft alles
nicht aus selbstlosigkeit passiert sondern letztendlich rein wegen stonks und geld aber
github ist immer noch eine gute plattform in der seite microsoft übernommen finde
ich eigentlich eher besser geworden ja sie schabt dort nett sind wunderbare technologien
von microsoft also man kann ja microsoft nicht mögen ist ja in ordnung aber die machen durchaus
gescheite sachen windows kommt mir auch nicht in die tüte also zu administrieren ich würde
im leben nicht winnows administrieren winnows ist der größte scheiß den es gibt der einzige
grund warum ich winnows verwende ist weil ich halt manche sachen am besten unter winnows
machen kann was aber an den programm liegt und nicht weil winnows so geil wäre
ich installiere mir kein winnows 11 ich installiere winnows 11 erst wenn winnows 10 end of life
ist oder es driftige gründe für gibt vielleicht mit dem nächsten rechner wenn die nächste
grafikkarten generation rauskommt und ich mir vielleicht endlich mal dann wirklich einen
neuen rechner baue dann dann mache ich vielleicht winnows 11 transformation zum fitness influencer
ja und face reveal alles in einem leute was hat man wenn man winnows 11 holt nee du hast
winnows 11 was sollst du sonst haben es näher es gibt schon ein paar ansätze zum
beispiel diese direct storage geschichten neuere direct x version die wahrscheinlich
so wie ich microsoft kenne dann nur für winnows 11 raus äh winnows 11 rauskommen du hast aber
auch viele nervigen sachen und ich verstehe halt nicht wie es microsoft immer wieder schafft
upgrades zu releasen die von den funktionen her weniger bieten als die sachen davor das
leuchtet mir halt nicht ein du ich würde auch nicht upgraden einfach so wenn es da nicht
irgendwie driftige gründe für gibt würde ich auch nicht upgraden mache ich ja auch
aktuell nicht ich upgrade ja nicht habe ich auch nicht vor erstmal ja accountpflicht
ist auch so ein abfuck ding weshalb ich das nicht machen würde sobald es accountpflicht
gibt gucke ich dass sie sich einen crack dafür gibt was kostet co-pilot eine gute frage bisher
war es kostenlos mittlerweile pricing mittlerweile kostet das was wo steht denn hier pricing
wir hatten diese seite wieder gemacht mann was kostet es denn
ich ich check wieder nicht wo ich den wo ich einfach ganz normal die preise sehen kann
wo war das hier ist nix nein das ist für github teams das ist nicht für co-pilot das ist
das ist für github nicht für co-pilot keine ahnung wieder so eine seite wo du nicht durchblickst
oder ich nicht durchblicke ja das hatte ich gerade auf so ganz oben hier also 10 dollar
im monat 100 dollar im jahr das weiß ich nicht ob es mir wert ist keine ahnung wie sieht
es bei euch aus chat kauft ihr es oder lasst es bleiben oder aber habt ihr keine ahnung
was github co-pilot überhaupt ist also ich weiß nicht ich werde es nicht kaufen geht
das mit allen idees oder nur wie es kaut das geht für alle idees und sachen wo es plugins
für co-pilot gibt jetbrains bundle beste habe ich auch die haben den preis erhöht
letztens um paar euro fürs jetbrains bundle ja schanken da kann ich dir jetzt so spontan
auch nicht helfen doch bin ich bin ich bin ich keck wer ist das service ja startup startup
ist schon fast gegründet der control enter ist jetzt aber das ist das ist die meistens
so code refactoring oder vorschläge wie man fehler ausbessern kann aber github co-pilot
macht ja schon mehr als dieses auto zeugs von jetbrains könnte ich mir einfach eine
edu domain registrieren und darüber darüber einfach das bundle kostenlos bekommen kann
man sich punkt edu registrieren omega keckel punkt edu das geht nicht unsupporte top level
wir müssen bloß ein domain registrar finden der da mitmacht ah leute genug geschwätzt
parmesan gibt es auch nichts ich bin müde wie sauber man vielleicht ich bin ja schon
halb am einpennen ich gehe schlafen leute bettgetheim boomer müde boomer schlafen
leute dit dit dit ja ich glaube gibt's sonst nix mehr oder ich will was wichtiges was wir
noch besprechen müssten ich glaube nicht alles klar dann sehen wir uns morgen bis denn
dann macht's gut, see you!